not really dating oh wait i am dating
wait no i'm not we i don't know what's
going on here
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode why are you laughing
because i didn't hear your countdown
just now so all of a sudden i was on
three and you started we're gonna keep
it going hello everybody welcome just
always criticizing me right in the
beginning
do you have something to say is there
who pissed in your cheerios this morning
who pissed in your cheerios you're our
time wait
please
take the floor my goodness
i can't do it anymore do you want to do
it marie hello everybody and welcome
back to another episode of the
unwax podcast with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine stallone
wow
that was a that was a good good start of
it good start i think we've had
maybe there's just a little bit of
tension i've been away from you
i just returned from new york i know a
few episodes back we talked about how i
went to new york fashion week was a
little bit nervous because i used to
live there and there was all this
old feeling but how did you
how you looked amazing i mean you went
to such cool shows you looked really
bomb thank you
it was a lot better being on that side
of it as opposed to being backstage and
doing the whole thing a lot of hair
tutorials tutorials you can speak i did
i went with um a hair brand so it was
the problem was there they thought that
i was more influencer than i actually am
and so yeah they said okay you need to
post this many tick tocks do these hair
tutorials explain it
i don't know how to do hair therefore i
mean i was telling sophia on the way
here how greasy and disgusting my hair
is so i had to go in a bun today i can't
do hair tutorials and now they're not
liking my tutorials it's a whole thing
but how did you feel about new york
being back there
so
weird i thought i was gonna love it i
thought i was gonna miss it i miss
nothing about being nothing and the
weirdest part was
i accidentally booked a hotel that was
right next to my old apartment
uh why would that be oh is that bad so i
really felt the
nostalgia the
yeah cause i remember you saying you
didn't love your experience in new york
when you lived there genuinely i was at
my lowest when i was living there and so
being on my street again
i thought oh my god i did go into my old
building though and say hi to the
doorman because i just said do you
remember me he's like no
you're like oh guys you're like
i remember the stories of when you lived
in new york your neighbor was was he a
pot dealer or something yes he did sell
drugs and a lot of parties and all he
did was his door was a revolving door
for women every single night and the
walls were thin let me tell you did he
ever try with you
he did oh good he did
he did and you know what
just no i was lonely they were friends
you know i thought why not get to know
my neighbor but yeah he was an
interesting dude he left really you know
not maybe people love new york i just
don't love it it's not for me i'll be
honest i go there for a weekend great i
love musicals i'll go to the museum so
that's what i do in new york like
sistine will go like the hot shot
restaurants and probably like meet up
with cool parties and friends me you
sound like i'm way cooler you are way
cooler the funniest thing is though i
actually went to new york with the
intention because it was fashion week
that oh
i'm gonna get invited to all these sick
after parties do you think one invite
came my way i literally made plans for
myself what do you think would have
happened to me if i was there no we
would have both not been invited
together well i knew that because
christine texted me randomly in the
middle of the day but i miss you and i
was like
we hang out 24 7. we live together we
work together no it was so sweet and the
fact that she missed me when we had like
maybe a couple days separation yeah the
fact that i missed you is a big deal i
would never do stuff like that no she
doesn't i literally talked about it with
my mom for probably oh yeah
yeah maybe i should text you more often
well you you just do that stuff it was
really nice i'm realizing this space is
actually really good for us yeah it is
we thrive on space we do why are we
living together i don't know i'm working
together no i'm serious why are we
living together
what do you mean why would we be living
together because i don't know who else
to live with you're like the easiest
person to live with ish
i mean i'm not saying i'm an angel
myself but i'm saying that compared to
other people already know your routine
okay you know fair well what did you do
when i was gone
um
i literally have no idea what i just did
i know what you did what did i do i got
us tickets to a museum and you took them
without me oh no that's not true you
wouldn't even like this museum it's the
van gogh interactive museum i'm the one
that booked it what are you talking
about talking about mom booked it
you didn't book it that's my idea no it
wasn't mom found it a magazine so i was
like let's go girls
i was trying to take you and then the
place canceled it because of covid
it was that same experience um
oh well sorry it was fun you missed out
you were in new york sorry at fashion
week i was at a van gogh museum sitting
on concrete floor with mom i did try to
take pictures of books for you did you
yeah to sext or not to sext right
it's very in
a lot of kids a lot of young adults like
to do it
but [ __ ] the icloud i don't trust it
i've turned it off yeah because i've
been hacked twice
not the vibe no i don't think people are
doing it as much anymore for that reason
no not as much everything no one sounds
like polaroid photos to the guy like
here i mean maybe they do
like just you can't still do that
how would you say in the mail send a
polaroid it'll get to you three to five
business days yeah that's true well i i
think people still do it maybe through
snapchat but like i don't i don't use
snapchat i feel old saying that because
i think everyone that's under the age of
18 or scarlett's age 20 uses snapchat as
a way to communicate well i'll tell you
what's disgusting i understand that
young kids are using snapchat to talk to
people because it's an easier
less committed way than asking for
someone's number
but when i have a grown-ass man asking
for my snapchat instead of my phone
number cut off what is that
wait do you remember the hot chef guy
that asked for snapchat first now he
just won't stop sending you you mean
creepy hinge chef oh hot chef guy sorry
that's hot gym guy
oh my god you guys remember hot gym guy
right
i ran into him on the street new york
can you believe it i said a guy and he's
like i have a name
okay i don't remember sorry you could
have the worst nicknames hot gym guy god
forbid also speaking about dating we're
talking about sexting or not to sex
whatever
one of the worst things
that we truly hate we feel like guys do
a lot is send voice memos
i don't know why you men think
we want to hear a two-minute message of
you talking about what you're doing that
day what am i up to
if we should go on a date or not it is
it honestly makes my skin crawl and the
reason why i'm bringing this up is
because while we're on the way here i
got a voice memo from someone honestly
like he probably is listening to this i
don't really want to get a voice memo
from i just have to interject really
quickly your passion is inspiring right
because
it really is but i have to say
everything that we've discussed so far
on this this episode we've blamed men
for being the problem
should we perhaps maybe look in a mirror
once in a while and say maybe we're the
problem why are we the problem i asked i
don't know
i think it's so funny that like all of
our dating mishaps and things that we
find wrong in the world we're like men
you did it you or something that's false
i will i will say i'm the first to make
a lot of mistakes in dating i know let's
continue about voice notes why do you
hate me so much i mean i think i'm less
i've gone voice memos less than you have
you are like the queen of getting
selfies from guys and voice members
solely like i've never seen anybody yeah
talk to their phone more than you do
because that's how they i hate i hate it
it gives me a different level of anxiety
i'd rather facetime this person but
getting a voice note first of all it's
like
creepy because then it expires
and then you only have two minutes to
think of a response and two minutes to
make sure your voice doesn't sound
like my voice on camera i mean you guys
know it's just i don't like the way it
sounds i think it sounds super deep and
sometimes you know i have morning voice
it's just a mess and then i get nervous
and have to reshoot it at least six
times instead of sending a [ __ ] text
that i can just say what i want you know
really i have a hack i have a hack if
you don't want to do that just make a
joke out of it use those um emojis or
use those things called emojis no no
shut up what is it called wait on your
phone you can uh make your face look
like an owl or a bear
emoji bitmoji that's the way
i just aged myself
um
use a bitmoji no that's not send
something back no that's not the point
why what's it's still your voice
you can change your voice that's a joke
because if it's a bear
i don't like the last person i was
talking to he only used voice note yeah
and then also another problem is you
can't remember
see i have a problem where i have a
really bad memory so a guy will tell me
something about himself and then i don't
remember it so then before a first date
sometimes i'll go back in the text
messages and like refresh you know oh
yeah you grew up in connecticut okay
i'll know that i'll remember that so but
in a voice note they all disappear
yeah
so i show up to this date with this guy
not remembering a single thing about him
it was stressful i didn't like it mine's
worse i usually repeat the same thing i
say over and over and they're like you
already told me that i'm like okay well
i'm telling you again don't tell me i've
told you that makes me feel so insecure
but you know what it's different what
i've gotten insulted via voice note i
remember this one hearing someone's tone
without a face is so intense it's worse
i would rather you say it to my face
than over 100 look i had sly draft up
this message and i said
this guy is just super weird like i have
to tell you guys the story later it's a
really good one it's a really good story
really good one but i said this guy is
just it ain't it sly what do i say
he gave me
honestly the most perfectly written text
message not a voice note
i've ever i've ever read send it to the
guy he responds just insulting me firing
jabs digging at me and i said oh my god
i feel like i'm more hurt if he had
typed it it wouldn't have been bad for
me yeah well you know what it is i think
that when you get a voice memo that's
almost like a
basically like a screw you breakup voice
memo you can't tell how their facial
expressions are because when you are
talking to someone you know that they're
probably going to come up with something
a bit more aggressive yeah but when
you're listening to it it's just in real
time
it's real time it's just like plot
twists and twists and i don't know it's
way worse i agree maybe that's the way
to if you ever are mad at your ex and
you want to really get them
just send a voice memo because it goes
away
wait that's actually you can't have
evidence
that makes you look crazy though that's
the thing it doesn't you can keep it
can you yes oh
never mind i was going to encourage
everyone just rant you got to do phone
calls that's it yes you can't have
evidence of you looking crazy
that is the unwaxed way okay no text
messages no videos because they'll
screen record it none of that oh i also
got a breakup video
that was also really hard to watch best
guys it's like three minutes of this guy
like just going on i go
you're done
the entire three minutes he was posing
he was flexing his jaw he was cursing
his lips out he's like if i'm not that
hot just tell me i'm like
like come on
like it was a trophy like he knows he's
attractive and i'm like okay the fact he
had to like acknowledge that
sorry he just it's not even about me
um should we talk about our guest that's
coming off yes i am super super excited
to have this girl on she is kind of
blowing up right now she is i feel like
she is a hot commodity
she's on basically everyone's podcast
she's blowing up on social media she was
on the netflix show too hot to handle
season two which i watched right when it
came i thought it was even better than
season one i binged it all the way
through yeah and
and we're here to have just girl talk
with her yeah we're not gonna make it
too interviewy but i wanna hear her tips
and tricks and things that you guys can
relate to and we just all have a girl
chat she was one of my favorites on the
show i know and we got her so stay tuned
and she's we got her coming up
[Music]
making her reality tv debut on season
two of netflix's show too hot to handle
our guest is exactly that you guys with
over 1.4 million followers this canadian
is making her mark in los angeles we
have the beautiful
stunning iconic carly lawrence with us
on wax today you guys
hey thank you so much for coming on
today having me this chick rolls up in a
ford raptor
i mean it's actually funny you should
take a picture of it i need to i was out
i was actually about to record it
if my phone was on well there's
something about a girl in a truck yeah
that just hits differently i mean it's
not my truck but i mean i do drive it do
you know don't tell them
yeah well guys like well like if i cut
someone off on that like the highway and
then they're like giving them they look
like oh no they're like no you're fine
no it's okay she's hot a little bit it's
too hot it's fine that's no big deal
that's sometimes what happens when i'm
in my mustang because it's a muscle car
so all these guys are like cool you've
been messing yeah i love that i used to
well my dad had a mustang they're the
easiest cars to drive yeah i need to get
it you should get that yeah i should i'm
telling
i hate the way it drives you feel every
pebble on the road
it's kind of like the truck too though
yeah a little bit i just can't drive it
i'm surprised i haven't crashed it
honestly i'm surprised you haven't
car and then you're going to hit on more
yeah true fair enough yeah
there's another hack wait so did you
just move to l.a recently i just moved
to l.a like two weeks ago i got a place
i'm canadian i'm from canada yeah okay
so yeah well
yeah it's been crazy yeah like it's just
so different here like toronto is very
like as much as it's like known as a big
city it's a very small town like so like
everyone knows who you are like when you
go to the bar it's like ever it's a
small store you come to elaine you're
like the smallest fish yeah and like the
pond like you go to the bar and
everyone's like who are you again
because you're like at the bar well it's
it's interesting because we've lived in
our la our whole life and you say
toronto is like a small fish small pond
but
even though la's a huge pond i feel like
everyone sort of knows everyone you're
going to be here for four months and
then you're going to realize that you
recognize everybody and you know
everything three spots to go out oh yeah
same thing i do already kind of feel
like that yeah even when you need people
i'm just letting you know everyone knows
honestly i'm not really dating oh wait i
am dating
wait no i'm not wait i don't know what's
going on here he's going to watch us
right all right so are we dating are we
not dating i don't know we're not like
dating but i'm definitely thinking but
the thing with me is that i don't sleep
around like if i'm sleeping with one
person
yeah to sleep like even if i start with
someone i wouldn't sleep around on him
okay so how did you meet him he lives in
l.a i dm'd him yeah he lives in alley
sophia
wait wait hold on back up dming because
i literally said this to cysteine in the
car i'm like i don't believe in dm'ing
anymore and that's only because every
time i've done it or you've done it it
doesn't work out that's not true that
was my first time dm excellent and how
did you do it i just said what did i say
to him he would know i said i think i
said what's up handsome no no i didn't
no i didn't no still that's cool oh no i
don't care what it is
no i said what's shaking i said what's
your shake oh that's even
shaken because he's like pretty like
weird like that and then he replied and
just sent me his number but see that's
it doesn't ha no it doesn't hurt that
you're gorgeous but see that's a really
smooth way to go in yeah you could be
cheeky funny i think it's funny i feel
like a lot of people like send us
messages and they're like how do we
slide in how's the right way yeah what
shaken i think that's safe shaking was
good i feel like you say anything that's
kind of funny like you can't be like
over like oh my god i want to hang out
with you like you know if a guy messaged
me like you know what someone else i
want to take you for like dinner oh my
god i know
don't respect me don't ask me out you
don't like me you don't like me like you
don't and then we were saying that too
we're like every time we like a guy and
we put in the effort for it it just
doesn't end up working out but the ones
i'm literally ignoring my friend's
obsessed with you by the way no no like
legit like so like he's a fuckboy and
was like i'm gonna marry her oh oh yeah
i know
wait which one is it of you hey i don't
remember now oh maybe it's
if you say his name maybe we know
garrett no he wouldn't if he wouldn't i
know what it is it's her who's garrett
because i saw the dm he sent wait did he
said did he send you he's on your idea
i said well
i know this is because he sent our
unwaxed a dm remember how
cecina we just remember i said it was
hilarious
because we were just talking about it
we were watching it was right
you know we were watching it with ryan
f boy island yeah
yeah i said oh
no no i mean like
you're a [ __ ] boy yeah no he's actually
not he's actually oh he's a nice guy
but yeah yeah okay guys okay i have
other hot friends you like steven kelly
i'm like
very single sophia
please okay well i have really hot guy
friends so perfect we love this already
they're great the only way to kind of
meet people now i don't even believe in
like dming anymore so i just don't think
it usually works out you just ignore i
want to go back to you being maybe
seeing someone maybe not sing something
okay so you dm him it works out you guys
meet up
so what sort of stage in the
relationship are you at currently
exclusive like he told me yesterday he's
not talking to girls oh he's first yeah
oh well he posted me on his instagram
too okay that's i think it's pretty
but it wasn't my face and he didn't tag
me
wait what was
it was just my butt oh that's cute
that's okay though i think i was like
laying on him i think that's like the
2021 way to say that we're exclusive i
agree yeah just like yeah i agree and if
it's a bad is that sad that like that's
our thing now like i don't think
like honestly i can't like think of it i
also have so many thoughts about
posting relationships in general it's a
lot i have never and i know i think has
been the same we've never posted a
boyfriend never tagged a boyfriend never
ever and
i just think it's negan's causes
they do get upset but girls like two
will go after your man like i found like
i will like
i i've seen this girl she was like going
for my ex and then like started seeing
my new guy [ __ ] followed him too i was
like okay shut up if you want to date me
you can dm me honestly
she's probably getting to the boyfriends
to get to you of course when i see that
and like
i say boys see it too oh absolutely
yeah but it's different because you
you had a very public relationship like
they were on the show you were dating a
i would not say a lot of people you
dated two people on the show well i
didn't even date the first one
like we never slept together or anything
like legit kiss twice on camera so
definitely it wasn't dating it was very
like but you came out of that show in a
full-blown relationship we weren't
dating post-show
so what happened was we left the show
like i really liked him and then right
when i flew home i was like i want to go
see him and within like a week i flew to
miami song
and then that's when we kind of hit it
off but then we had a breakup then after
the show came out then we got back
together but i think he dated me post
show
for like clout reasons
um how is the difference between like
dating on the show and then dating
well i guess like real life yeah so i
guess when we couldn't post anything
it was like was it good because you guys
had to be interested it was more like
fun and then as soon as like was posting
more it kind of felt more of like not
like a job but it kind of felt more like
that's like why we were dating right did
you feel like the fans sort of kept the
relationship going 100
because when everyone's like shipping
you you're like well i want to stay in
like if everyone loves you together
maybe like i should love scale yeah and
then when the night we broke up
obviously and i like posted everything i
was like
so cool would you say that maybe this
relationship wouldn't even worked out
yeah
interesting yeah just saying no not at
all interesting is there an age gap
between you guys same age same age same
age do you like dating older or younger
older always
data was my age
i don't think we've dated anyone well i
like to
subtract eight years from a man just
because like mentally i think they're
eight years younger than they really no
i i always have to go older my one of my
exes was 14 years older than me and it
was great oh that's awesome
how was it like did they treat you well
um or do you think they're honestly the
same because i honestly it was the same
see
doesn't
how is he clever about it because sophia
and i are are very public about
how we are able to investigate in stock
man yeah you suck
oh yeah well but we do i need to get you
girls to stop for me because i don't
stop sophia is basically the ciao
me too i have no idea what's going on
i'm like ted bundy or a nice guy i don't
know yeah sophia will do i have like
less failing relationships just because
i figured it out before before see
that's that's probably my problem yeah
and i wish i wasn't like that but at the
same time i think that it's good to kind
of get like a grasp on who they are and
everything comes to surface eventually
too and that's another thing i think
guys don't realize is that girls find
out everything and the two days before
my breakup i was in a podcast room and i
had said like the only way i'm gonna
find out if something's going on is like
if another woman tells me because i find
like that's like a oh yeah and that's
how i did it
like and i love that i love girls for
that i'd like find it like if a woman's
gonna like tell another woman your man's
not
in chat yeah [ __ ] all the power to you i
respect that so much i would never turn
a girl down for telling me something so
is that how you found out yeah you got
cheated on the last relationship the
girl told you yeah
and the thing is they sent a little
private so i had a lot of fake accounts
sending it to me but they would send
videos oh okay
i have a question because you just said
you were cheated on before that yeah how
do you like trust in a relationship
after getting i don't yeah that's why my
brain's like always checked out that's
why like another thing is she was like
post relationship everyone's like you're
moving on so quickly and i'm like
but realistically i have been mentally
checked out because i knew stuff was
going on right so it's like as much as i
just say like i also give a lot of guys
chances like i will give and give and
give me to the point where i'm finally
like oh okay i'm i'm so over it a
hundred percent now i'm more like [ __ ]
if you're not going to change no i'm
like
i've
come to the realization where i will
give second chances third chances four
chances and i'll try to fix people and
try to make them the person that i want
them to be but in reality
i realize okay maybe it's not the men
that i'm dating because i can't change
them maybe it's me
avoiding my own problems and dealing
with my own issues that i'm going to
project that energy onto them right do
you feel like
you have trust issues was that something
that you dealt with before you even
started seeing men um yeah i guess so i
mean i don't really know i've never
really i know it's kind of a loaded
question i think i haven't really ever
stayed in relationships that long i kind
of jumped [ __ ]
four years that's a pretty long yeah
that was long that was in college that
we also like oh it was like we had like
the same friend group like
foreign group and it was just like easy
was just like we were in the same
but we had a great relationship it was
like the easiest breakup and the easiest
relationship i've ever been it was
probably the most healthy relationship
ever see isn't that funny it's like my
healthiest was high school what the hell
why can't it be simple like that and
also social media is such a big thing
right so social media you can look at a
million other girls and other guys and
quickly your brain's like no they're
always on to the next like and that's
why i think another reason i got over my
exo coffee too there was like
a million people in my dms like the
night after and i was like okay there's
always more out there not like
necessarily i was looking but it was
just like well that's the problem
because now that everyone has like 100
options i know yeah i'm not hard at that
are you okay so we won't talk too much
about the guy that you're seeing but is
he more in the public eye
not really i'd say i'm more now yeah
okay i would say he was when he was
younger
he was like he's like been famous for a
while but i would say me more now it's
more in spotlight for sure doesn't say
that it's totally a difference between
dean someone that's in like the public
eye versus
like do you prefer like one or the other
or i feel like i would want now private
but then i also like being shown off
like i also like the fact that he's
been kind of public about it yeah it's
part of the reason though that you like
to be shown off
because by the way so do i every girl
wants to feel like you know their man is
putting them on a pedestal but
i feel like for you in particular
because you're on social media and
because you came off the show i mean
your fan base is so strong yeah and i
couldn't even imagine
the amounts of girls in like your man's
dms yeah of course i mean it doesn't
doesn't that make you feel like anxious
or insecure like how do you deal with
that honestly it doesn't i actually get
really jealous yeah that's something
i've been working on and stuff and i'm
working there but now i just kind of i'm
like if a guy's not gonna make me feel
great i gotta go good for you like
really yesterday i was like kind of
feeling a little bit iffy he's never
gonna watch this so [ __ ] it yeah i felt
was kind of feeling off and then i was
like
what am i what the heck am i doing right
and then i had two his friends over and
we made dinner oh that's fine not like
in that way but that's that's that's
like yeah i don't need to like wait i'm
not gonna wait around and then i told
him not to on the phone too i was like
if you're not gonna be able to like
be the type of man that i yeah then i
have to go what type of man do you want
i don't know it's too tight
i like girls too okay i said that i um
i always get asked that online um i
think i just like someone that's really
loyal obviously
on social media off social media
whatever like i don't hate when you like
look through your man's legs and it's
all girls you're like oh god yeah to me
like that's all
bikini instagram girl bikini that's a
good point yeah bikini not like a face
like it's a friend
like [ __ ] butt like that's so
unattractive to me yeah that's why i
can't even look i'm the type of person
where it's out of sight out of mind i
will absolutely the only thing that i've
me all of my ex is muted but they're all
of my close friends for strategic
reasons
and she's really smart about this
actually this is pretty good see i don't
know your closest friend
i have all of them and my close friends
just because i want to see if they're
looking at my stories and so you'll post
a second
story to the public right and then the
next and then the next one it could be
just like a photo of your water bottle
and then you can see if they actually
like watch yourself and then also
another tip is like if you want to like
act like you blocked your man you just
go on airplane mode but you still get
the text
oh i never knew this i saw tick tock
so i was like genius so it's like
[ __ ] blocking you airplane and then
you can still see what they text you and
then you on turn airplanes come through
but they'll think is that jesus that's
actually really scary
i haven't done it i mean i haven't
fought with him yet so i guess
i know he will watch it so he won't know
perfect that's actually really smart i
know really smart i need to find a guide
to do that too 100 yeah
i feel like i need a roster i think i
won't be satisfied more than one i just
feel bad yeah i know i think just stick
with if it's yeah well i think stick
with no one honestly i think i should i
was going to say you you're
just recently living in l.a it's a new
city yeah lots of options right now tons
of options in my career i launched my
podcast on wednesday i don't talk about
that yeah let's talk about so what's it
called now the fun starts i came up with
a name like legit before my first girls
came in the room really i was sitting
with my abbey like my creative guy and i
was like because he said something about
my ex and i was like well now the fun
starts and he's like that's your name i
was like yes that's actually awesome
starts so it comes out wednesday it
comes out wednesday every wednesday i'm
not sure i'm gonna put it on on first so
i already filmed a few different
episodes but i'm not sure which ones i
want to do like what i want to do first
so why did you decide to start a podcast
honestly because i did a few and
everyone was like she needs her own
podcast and then also i was like it's
nice when like something happens in the
media and like also like
anything i do is like posted on reddit
like wildfire and i'm like it's nice to
have my own side of the story right you
know i don't need to go on podcast to
say i can say it on my own 100 that's
another thing too and it's something to
be said to like it feels good just to
have one mic and just talking and being
like this is coming from like yeah the
person's mouth like that's how i feel
then you can kind of like create the
narrative also that you want to put out
there rather than people like
fabricating something because i don't
want to be on my story saying oh like
this is what it actually happened like
that's like yeah it's just a great
platform too like young girls like
message me daily like confidence and
like this and like our moms will message
me oh my god my daughter is like so
insecure how do i make it feel better
i'm like i would love if like if i was
younger to be able to listen to someone
that could maybe make me feel better
because i didn't have that growing up
hundred percent i mean like i couldn't
just turn on the podcast and like feel
better right that's kind of how we kind
of started our podcast because we're
like we really want to find a podcast
where it's just two sisters like
bringing on guests and we just kind of
be your older sisters or a younger yeah
of course just have like a conversation
yeah of course and so it's like there's
a good it's always good to have like a
reason to go into it not just like going
oh like because of social media like
you're like i want to help people i want
to help people first yeah and also it's
like great to be vulnerable and you seem
like super open which is i'm pretty open
which kind of bites me in the ass
sometimes same here but it's like but
i'm like you know what that's who you
are you would either stay quiet and be
judged or say your opinion that's what
my therapist says she's like carly you
could shut your mouth your whole life
and you will still be judged so might as
well use your voice i was warning you
that your ex will probably listen to
your podcast really all of ours have can
i tell you literally
until two weeks ago i got approached my
mind and said stop talking about me like
y'all like [ __ ] actually
definitely well he listens
they always say they won't but then
every time they'll come back and be like
that one time that you said that would
you like the [ __ ] did you know how did
you know what's going on what was that
what the heck's going on no it's
literally i'm like i wasn't talking that
wasn't your date i was talking another
day i'm like you listen to me talk for
45 minutes yeah
amazing good we love it we love to see
it we think about how has it been living
with a boy good great great we live with
our cousin and he's a guy so i've got
along with boys i love girls but like i
haven't had many girlfriends in my life
i find well in high school and an
elementary school like bully blocked by
a girl so i never really got along with
him i always was closer tell us tell us
about that because we've had very
similar experiences i just like hated i
remember just like
was so nervous on my school to go to
school because like this one girl i
remember i hated it and remember she's
like she ripped she cut apart my little
lemon pants and like whoa put my
headband in the sink like she was just a
bullet like mean like she was really
mean and since then i was like no plus i
have an older brother right and i hung
with him and all his friends so i just
always was close to men so i just killed
him they're already like acclimated with
boys anyway so it was easy to transform
my three best friends here are guys well
two guys and then i have my one
girlfriend how is like the living
differences even with dating because i
know that archives and like help bring
home girls it's just like a totally
different way like like we try to figure
out a way to not like interject or like
at least be not he doesn't bring home
girls oh
he doesn't it's kind of nice though yeah
he doesn't bring home girls so it's
actually fun he brings from his guy
friends which are my guy friends so it's
fun it's just like it's always a big
party at my condo honestly
i don't really ask for advice are you
pretty good at like texting and dating i
don't really yeah i feel like i just do
what i think would be right like how i
want to like treat them sometimes i
don't really
play games like i feel like if i want to
text someone i'll double text someone or
if i don't want to text you piss me off
i just won't answer you
i don't think too much into it
look i'm so not about playing games as
well yeah sophia goes
if he writes me 20 minutes and didn't
answer
25. like i don't i don't well
[Applause]
but it's like i mean
i'm not if a guy's ignoring me i'm not
gonna like [ __ ] text you no i
wouldn't go like that yeah so that's
like more of my thing i'm like if you're
not giving me the energy i'm not going
to give you of course me either [ __ ]
that so it's like tit-for-tat yeah what
has been your experience though
because you said that you had like
trouble meeting girlfriends or at least
i know for my experience living in los
angeles i've lived in my life and i have
such a hard time meeting girls yeah have
you experienced any like fakeness or
people that want something and then
underpin your background oh well you're
not that's just the stuff one girl was
like just super chasing and just
trying to just we weasel her way in but
i i feel like
like
oh i can smell it i have one girlfriend
here really honestly this was so
exciting to meet you guys
yeah i know i literally was like staying
full to garrett and like my friends
though
they're coming to my dinner on wednesday
because my lunch is wednesday oh and i'm
having an event on sunday saturday i'm
like i'm going to invite them because i
have no girls i have one girlfriend well
we would love that because
you don't have
i grew up girlfriends one girlfriend we
went to the same school every year since
uh through college yeah she moved to new
york i literally have yeah
i have it's like my sister's my friend
right that's more i feel the same way
and by the way you only need one friend
yeah yeah that's all you need no it's
true yeah i mean i have one i have more
guy friends too yeah i mean
when people are like that's a red flag
when a girl has more guy friends who
gives a [ __ ] about gender just in
general who cares about that to each
whatever you want to do i don't give a
[ __ ] about that i totally call yourself
a butterfly okay i think okay
i feel like you thrive do you thrive
being single because i can tell you
everyone tells me to be single all the
time
being in a relationship is because i
give them a hundred percent and then
it's like and then it's okay but when
i'm single i'm focused like i'm dialed
in right that's why right now i think
for like at least the next month i
should keep it very single just because
i'm launching like so much stuff's
coming out i'm working that's how we
kind because when we were starting this
podcast and everything we're like you
know what like let's just focus on our
work and honestly it's really fun it is
because i feel like you're pretty
confident are you a confident person
would you say or i don't know i'm
thinking you're like learning how to i'm
learning but for my podcast i'm really
nervous yeah like what everyone listens
to it wonderful let me tell you let me
tell you sophia and i we this is our
we're like past 50 episodes now 50. yeah
and so we saw this last august and we
literally started it thinking okay we're
gonna say whatever we want in front of a
microphone half of it's gonna be you
know advice that no one's gonna take
yeah we have no idea what we're talking
about we're just gonna blabber and no
one's gonna listen but if one person
listens and it helps them in any sort of
way it's worth it yeah and it's gonna
work for you because as you see it grow
it's funny we actually didn't even see
our numbers or what what our listeners
are until maybe last month yeah i don't
want to see mine and we were shocked
people listen like and then you have
girls coming up to you on the street and
they'll say we love your show we're like
miami you listen to us we're coming up
together like we love your show on wax
and we're like oh my god there are
people listening and honestly the
biggest advice i would just say is
people can smell out if you're being
honest or not yeah and being vulnerable
like we just we totally expose ourselves
for like mental health
um everything yeah i tell myself every
day
about dating like talk about your
embarrassing date stories like that's
literally all we do yeah it it ends up
being really fun and it's a little
therapy session for yourself no it is a
theory after i film a podcast it feels
so good oh yeah yeah i'm like
i'm like i don't need my therapist
anymore i don't go to therapy
session i'm done what are we choosing to
want to be chasing um
girls and new friends friendships
that was good
oh that was delicious oh we don't even
like
chase which is not a flex that we
shouldn't i do have two spots
it is
i have a concert i'm going to are you
going to glass animals no i should go to
cuba
[Laughter]
so since you've been in la and i know
it's been like probably the biggest
transition what's this like been the
biggest difference do you think you've
seen from like i guess going to like a
bar that like i know everyone and then
going out to a bar here and i'm like
right
everyone hates me no like not actually
like you know what i mean like
everyone's kind of more like stuck up
here do you feel that way that sometimes
when you like walk in your room you're
like everyone's judging me everywhere
just because people are in like their
own clicks i feel like yeah and like
there's different like levels to the the
clicks see that and i'm at like my own
random like
right spiderweb
are you an overthinker yes okay oh my
god did you were you in like therapy
before you came onto the show or like in
l.a or did you join it when you came
here i did therapy now i was little yeah
and then i stopped and then post show
because i was literally out of whack
like on the show you legit are like you
have a heart like a life coach it's not
really like a life coach but it's like
the whole team is like the whole
productionist because like yeah they put
you to bed they turn the lights off they
turn the lights on it's like you're
literally on a schedule eating sleeping
filming getting changed doing your
makeup how long
i would love to know
what the schedule was what time did you
have to wake up 8 a.m i think we did
wake up and then sleep and then sleep
was like 10.
so legit early we're like 11. but like
you're legit put in bed and taken out of
bed at a time like it's not like you can
lounge in bed and like go on your phone
you're up you're getting ready you're
filming it so i have i have so many
questions about this and i don't i think
a lot of people understand the logistics
of reality tv we don't even need to get
into all of that she didn't even know
she was on too out to handle no no
i would have looked way better if i knew
did you guys see me on that what the
[ __ ] i thought you were going to
actually watch the first episode last
night just to like get a wreath like
yeah white and we were like your bathing
suit was the best yeah we're like you
looked hot you looked amazing i looked
terrible but it's totally fine wait did
you know anybody going into the show at
all no no i hadn't watched your tunnel
for a season so i legit do nothing i
brought vance and like sneakers and the
girls had like palm side like two pairs
of people do they dress yeah no
they bought me makeup there like i was
so you're unprepared i was ready to get
[ __ ] up it was called parties and
paradise parties
how did you find parties in paradise
i don't remember how did you my party
and i was just like it's a scam and then
it was so much testing and videos and
chats and this person this producer and
this background and the psychological
testing i was like it's not a scam so
yeah did they ask you certain questions
to sort of
because i remember seeing your questions
i was gonna say like i remember in your
intro
if you were on par parties yeah the
island or whatever the [ __ ] it was
paradise party's a paradise of the
island what is the place i love i was i
was wondering because your whole intro
is strictly just about like sex meaning
you're calling yourself a man eater and
yeah dating
stories they pull it out of you they
pull it out of you right and so i was
wondering because
obviously reality tv magic they can make
you look a certain way with editing make
you sound a certain way you can be the
nicest girl in the world yeah but they
could cut it up and make you sound like
a total ass of course so yeah was what
was portrayed on tv accurate or do you
feel like they sort of gypped you
sometimes
for me i think they portrayed me really
well oh good i think i did i think my
feedback post show was probably the i
would say like some of the best from the
girls
because but then again i i just was
myself but for the guys i feel like
they portrayed them a bit worse for that
for two out to handle it's like
they really portray the best that they
can yeah right like that's the best
reality show you can get on oh yeah like
realistically like like there's no
better than that i mean the exposure
like love island just doesn't compare
nothing else the u.s one is just not the
total would be the best thing that i
could have gone on
and that was the one that i did but they
portrayed me pretty great i thought did
you ever think that you'd end up in the
position you're in now no like what did
you want to be before
i kind of knew i was going to be like
kind of in like in the limelight but i
was remember i was bartending and i was
like what am i going to do with my life
i thought about getting into like real
estate oh you posed me so many tips yeah
i just like didn't know yeah i didn't
yeah that wasn't sorry but i just didn't
know i went to his life and then this
came up but like that's how it happens
right it was just like out of the blue
and i was like [ __ ] it like what am i
doing but like it's weird because
knowing me and my anxiety like i would
never think that i'd be like on a plane
by myself in turks and caicos with no
phone quarantining and then on a show
that's really scary it makes you really
independent really quickly yeah like
they're like something that i went
through that like no one was gonna do
that in their life like that's like a
one in a billionth chance oh i don't
know what i've done yeah yeah why not
because i think even with anxiety you
just never think that you're gonna put
yourself in that position to make
yourself maybe not anxious and then you
realize like we actually can well is
that how you were feeling while filming
because to us like the viewer you looked
so confident and real and spoken and
didn't have the best time in the house i
was going to say like i did not have the
most time why not um
i don't know i think
i don't know it's hard to say because i
don't want to like out anymore no you
don't have to out anyone but i
definitely was only close to like a few
two people yeah okay other than that i
will say i didn't necessarily find the
rest of everyone well i mean it's a
rarity to find like an entire group of
people that you live very small yeah
like ten different personalities yeah
yeah you know like [ __ ] people
exactly competitive woman
oh no everyone's there for themselves
everyone's gone
and that's why i learned pretty quickly
i'm here for myself so right i mean like
i would have personally felt extreme
anxiety just being socially it was
always a therapist i thought which was
great that's good
i don't know how you would have done it
i liked it
i couldn't done with the therapist there
they had a therapist on site and legit
anytime you're feeling upset like a
producer or talk to you like they would
come up like i remember one night when
me and chase broke up on the shows i
went outside the room and i was crying
and within like seconds i'm not kidding
you like three producers came up and
it's out with me although wow like they
are so good at being there for you like
they were netflix does an amazing job of
like with like mental health mental
health for sure are you a big advocate
on that like 100 percent see i like that
people talk about because it's really
something that's like so dumb to make it
like a hush-hush talk yeah no they were
there they they did it so right like and
they made me go through like a breakup
online but it was so easy because like i
had so much support
so it's like now moving forward like
that's why my last breakup like i wasn't
like sad about it because you were able
to like because i was able to just like
cool like i would cope open the house
and it was like give space from the
person and then like just don't talk so
you learned a lot from i did learn a lot
from the show actually my girlfriend
asked jolie asked me last night she's
like dude like how do you feel a dating
potion i'm like i just like i'm way
better at dating i find like i care less
oh good not like in a bad way but like
i'm just like what would you tell girls
then that are going through a breakup
take space
take space is the biggest thing don't
creep the social media right the more
you look the more you're gonna be would
you say block
i would say block because i find
blocking shows you really care
and i don't like the only one that
satisfaction right i did block my exo
and he asked me to unblock him and i
didn't i haven't blocked him now
but at the time i said why do you think
he asked though let's let's dive into
that because he probably wanted my his
tags to saw me tagged oh see that's the
see and that's when it comes down to
selfishness and like that's what i don't
like
i feel like with every breakup with
every relationship even friendships you
sort of realize what you didn't get in
that one and what you want for the next
of course what do you feel like you
didn't get in the last one and you're
like okay i would love to find this next
one i didn't get anything from that
relationship oh my god
nothing carly oh my god guys i paid for
everything for that man everything
breakfast lunch dinner staying he had
his whole life covered and then even
past that he was talking to girls in my
back see like and i was like bro you're
going to use my card and then still
cheat on me so yeah you got
nothing you said from your last
relationship nothing like that sounds
mean but like i don't know i need to be
honest like legit nothing but a lot of
people can relate to that because i
think that some people go like i thought
i was like trying so hard to make it
something i tried like yeah exactly but
then it just doesn't end up being
anything you're like okay maybe if i pay
if maybe if i do this maybe if you do
that like
something will come up that he benefits
so what would you like for the next one
that's a good question or maybe just one
thing they're like well i guess loyalty
like honestly and to feel not used like
that would be nice that would be
genuinely nice to not feel like i'm like
being used like right i feel like i was
used for clout i was used for financial
reasons i was used because he wanted to
move here we couldn't afford it so he's
like well free ride you know oh my god i
was like so gross looking back i hate it
like i don't hate him like
that but
like that sounds so bad like like girl
to girl i don't like him i think he's a
terrible person no i don't think anybody
in a relationship like that should feel
great afterwards like
sometimes it's hard because how long
were you guys together
december january see it's a while it's
like a really long time
when you're in a relationship that you
don't realize is toxic or not good for
you
sometimes you're just so consumed on
focusing on okay i want to make it work
and i want to make this person like me
and i want to teach this person to do
these things sometimes you're just
beating a dead horse there's nothing
that you can do yeah and you lose sight
of what
is good for you and like you you don't
put yourself as a priority and now i
mean it's amazing that you can sit back
and say it was a bad mistake for me it
wasn't a good move i'm going to learn
and move on for the next one but it's i
mean it's tough we've all been there for
me it was like i wasn't even like trying
to like make it work it was like i felt
like i was like his babysitter like i
felt like if i didn't feed him
like no one's gonna get him food like
that's legit why i stay with him because
i felt bad like i was like he doesn't
have money his career like my career is
like i work really hard for like what
i'm trying to accomplish in my life
right and i felt like i was like trying
to pull him up with me right and i felt
bad i was like no one's gonna help but
it stops your growth too it's also my
growth but now i look at it and i'm like
what's he really doing like not under me
no really it sends me like what the
[ __ ] he doing right like i don't know
no but i think that's the best thing is
when you cut off the things that are
holding you back look at you now like
you are literally having your own
podcast you found a person no and you're
not saying that that's how you know it
smell not good no no no no but it's not
a great feeling yeah it's it no
seriously
but that's when you know you made the
right choice when you leave a
relationship and you almost feel lifted
yeah i felt like that i feel like i can
be single i could date people i could
focus on my work yeah better myself and
you're doing all of those yeah i know i
did amazing but you also like even if
you weren't with the guy and it didn't
end up working out like you still feel
like okay if i had a shitty date with
someone i can still like move on and be
fine yeah right 100
i'm actually i'm curious have you ever
been like on a really bad date
i you know it wasn't like a really bad
date i was seeing someone and i was with
one of my best friends at the time and i
talked about this on the show and we
went back to his house and i guess i was
like so drunk i fell asleep or whatever
i just fell asleep okay girl [ __ ] was
like 5 a.m and i woke up she was like
[ __ ] stick beside me
stop it stop it stop it stop it i didn't
even care i didn't even care
because i was like well he's never going
to be in my life
how many dates was this in well we were
like seeing each other like more than
just date like we were like together
probably yeah and you're like okay i was
just like well he was never going to be
in my life ever so i was like is it
really getting worth worked up but you
like really have thick skin yeah i
really just don't care no but you've
been there
by the way that's a story that a lot of
girls would care and like you've been
through it i didn't even care i just
like woke up and i was like i'm gonna go
home like you can finish
what's
a guy like paid for my dinner
so please oh someone has all right all
right guys please
where are you meeting these men i don't
know the dumpster the dumpster okay
i would love a psa do you i hope all the
men listening right now psa
buy her dinner open the door for her
compliment her when you first see her
little things we remember
pretty i literally spent time to put
like pain and if you're gonna post my
ass and your story at least tag me thank
you yeah you know what i would like to
be called pretty that would be nice my
ex never called me pretty ever oh my god
sophia and i go crazy but some guys
aren't good at giving compliments so i
don't judge him on that
no but i'm saying is that bad for me to
say [ __ ] you it is it is i don't know
why tell me yes
we get so upset if a girl gets ready for
a date yeah she spends maybe an hour two
hours preparing for money too nice maybe
she gets a blow out you don't know
eyebrows lashes and it's like if the
first thing that doesn't come out of
your mouth when you see her is oh my god
you look so beautiful
by the way dudes if even if you don't
think she does just say it say it yeah
she'll feel so good yeah it's true she's
gonna take compliments
quicker
yeah it's just and pay for the dinner if
it's the first date just like wait pay
for it i've been on a date in so long
what are you wait wait wait wait wait
wait does it sound like i don't know but
you know i'm taking you guys
we're taking you on a date okay okay
i go early do i go for bad men yes yes
we'll find you just
because i found myself a winner over
here please don't watch this
no he hasn't taken me for dinner but
only he got me curry at night at his
house no no no no
buttered chicken though
butter chicken
i [ __ ] love indian food's my favorite
type of food i love this but anyways he
bought me that so okay okay we like
indian food
we know a great spot
we'll take it okay and one day for you
and come forward we're taking you on a
date i'm so excited
i'll wear a dress for you me really yeah
i'm putting on kittens
oh my heels you don't wear heels and i
will for you i wear pumps oh [ __ ] oh i
always wear heels
me too i always wear heels in public
though like for for a night out you
gotta this has been
actually exceeded my expectations like i
knew i was going to love you but i like
now i know it is love you guys too it's
this it's my boobs are sweating that's
okay we're all sweating we're all sweaty
by the way we have oil sheets we were
literally just dabbing we're hoping that
the people watching this will just think
it's highlighter and not ourselves no i
legit i'm sweating down my boob no you
look incredible
yeah hide it with the hair okay i'm
ready for those oh no you completely
exceeded the expectation you know
sometimes when you meet girls for the
first time you never know if you're
going to vibe
i feel like this is
made to happen i'm excited to come on
your show yeah we're gonna tell the
listeners where they can find your
podcast your instagram everything carly
lawrence underscores my instagram my
youtube is karlie lawrence and my
podcast instagram is now the fun starts
yay we're so excited for you thank you
guys for tuning in and we'll see you
next week bye
[Music]
[Music]
you